I think the most I mean what was most
important to me and and thankfully Scot
was that you know that the way to
approach the film the way to approach
the character was not was not as a
criminal or not as if you know evil or
any of that stuff because I don't you
know I don't think there's anyone of us
who were but there's probably a few evil
people here if you're working Holly I've
been called evil just to not approach
Jimmy as a criminal per se or you know
because none of us wake up in the
morning and shave a brush our teeth
thinking I'm gonna go out and absolutely
destroy people wanted to see I wanted to
see the human side of that I wanted to
understand that there was a great
difference between his life and the
people that he loved and the people that
he was loyal to people that he truly had
that traditional Irish immigrant bond
and love for his for his mother love for
his brother and that the other side was
business you know business is business
and it just so happens that his business
required a great deal of violence
because the only way to stay on top and
so yeah it wasn't like I would was
trying to glorify any of his actions but
just to give the opportunity to see a
human being as opposed to justice you
know just is multifaceted individual mr.
Bulger so that's really what Scott and I
talked about it yeah otherwise it's it's
it's too easy for an actor to come in
and just play one color of venality but
one color of violence so Johnny really
approached him is okay this is a human
being who happens
be cold and cunning and calculating but
also very tender with moments with
Dakota's character with his humorous
with his mother otherwise it trivializes
everything that occurred in Boston
because there's so many emotional scars
in that city that really have yet to to
heal that everyday Johnny and I would go
to set we would always say there were
victims and victims families so we
cannot in any way make this feel like an
overt movie in which were glamourizing
and glorifying them those moments with
Julianne are extremely menacing and the
moments with Dakota are extremely tender
until that moment in the kitchen of the
or the cafeteria of the hospital in
which we see how he begins to turn right
Dakota I would ask about that scene
that's obviously the death of the son is
something that I guess for the first
time Jimmy can't control he is not a
master of and it's also one of the few
times that somebody stands up to him he
talked a little bit about the scene in
the hospital and how important it is in
terms of what it reveals about Jimmy and
about about your character and somebody
who can stand up to him in this horrible
moment of heartbreak at that point their
child was still technically alive
although on life support and so there's
a time when thus far basically he's he's
been a completely different person with
her and and it's kind of been private
and it's only they she sees a side of
him that nobody else gets and he's been
good to her and and been wonderful to
their child and then the minute that she
shows you know sort of I feel like in in
moments in in experiencing trauma
profound psychological changes happen so
you know he turns on her and it's it's
like that just the darkest side of him
because until then it's been it's been
only you only see peace when they're
together I want to come back to the
scene with Julianne upstairs David I
want to talk about the way in which that
scene was cut it's there's not a lot of
cutting and that scene actually we see a
lot of
of Johnnie's hands on Julian's face can
you talk about the editing that's and
then we'll talk a little bit about the
score in it well there's a I think in
the editing room one of the things we
talk about it's it's a lot easier to cut
than it is not to cut so with
performances and and by the way Julian
wasn't the only one who was surprised
when Johnny came through the door and
that scene because I wasn't there on the
set that day it's not written that way
so when I sat down the next day and saw
the dailies I was and I watched Julian's
take first and there weren't a lot of
takes I mean this but it was it was
frightening it was horrifying and I kind
of got well there's nothing there's no
way to cut away from this I mean it's
just what's going on there but then on
the other side you do have Johnny Depp
but the star of the movie and so you
know you're going to have to go there at
some point so it was just trying to find
the right moment where you could
possibly go away from with Julianne when
Scott asked me to come down and and see
the film I had a I had a flu and I am so
me I call so so I didn't sleep for many
many nights in a row and I come in at 9
o'clock I see this film and I got out by
11:00 and my hands were sweating and my
legs were trembling and I was supposed
to meet that the two of you actually
after that and I the meeting was very
short I was like okay I need to collect
myself and I'll let's call it later this
afternoon but by that time I got so
inspired and I said to Scott let me
write a theme or something and then I'll
send it to you and if you like it I if
you recognize your movie and this I'd
love to work with you on this it got a
little out of hand it became 45 minutes
and it is the most amazing thing I've
ever seen and I just got on this really
weird trip it's like oh we need to do
this we need to do that and and the
nights got shorter the days got longer
but I got more and more inspired the flu
disappeared by the way and so I sent it
out to Scott's and I said like hey do
you recognize you
and you called me back within an hour
two hours and so a lot of the material
that was written was was in this 45
minutes and the things that were in
there were anger paranoia very tender
sweetness and and also very emotional
music and the point from that point
almost like between Scot me and David
was was the dynamic is like okay where
do you restrain on your music and you to
avoid to put a hat on a hat you know
which is very hard to do with with with
movies like this because the acting is
so incredibly strong and that took you
know quite some experimentation John
lusher this is a project that was in
development for a number of years and
then something happened in 2011 in June
of 2011 that changed its trajectory what
happened and how did that change this
this project they found Whitey Bulger
hiding in Santa Monica
from here five miles that far from here
and yeah was I it was always this thing
I thought would be cool but as we all -
it felt like we were just missing so
much information and even a third act or
something or just something that and
from the moment they found him and then
through the trial not only did it
illuminate so much more information on
what these guys were all up to and what
the FBI was up to and everything but it
also it gave us the kind of impetus and
the energy to go make the movie the
ability to go get people like Scott and
Johnny and everyone but setting all
these amazing people that worked on it
we have just an amazing crew that worked
on this movie from top to bottom and our
cast so anyway that thanks to Scott
together how did you discover whitey and
was it a process was it gradual was
there some sort of Epiphany and how
important was the wardrobe and makeup in
that discovery they go hand in hand for
me you know um just like wardrobe can be
look like a suit of armor in a way can
it it almost dictates how you stand you
know it'll change your posture so things
start coming to play
the makeup the prosthetics I've been
working for many many years with a
amazing makeup artist especially with
prosthetics guy named Joel Harlow who ya
amazingly work amazing and and Joel is a
perfectionist and you know he started
making these sculptures and sculpting
pieces and what none we did about five
or six Tests until we both looked at it
and thought yeah that's that's him you
know that's him and sure it's Scott and
whatnot and and we move forward but
having you know wearing wearing the
pieces and knowing that it was it did
allow me to transform physically and
also you i mean the this distance
surveillance footage on on Jimmy Bulger
we see at the end of the film yeah yeah
exactly and there's not there's not much
else really and there's very little
audio of him so I I just kind of I
listen to it I talked to I spoke to a
lot of people in Southie who were former
associates and I I was able to glean a
lot of information I spoke to his
attorney who was very clear she guy
named Jay Carney's wonderful guy he I
went to him and requested a meeting if
possible with joining the Belcher and he
had respectfully declined as he wasn't
basically enthusiastic about this book
or any book that's been written
as you can imagine he's writing his own
buck that's what I've heard sequel but
you know Jay Carney was very upfront he
said listen I'm not going to I'm not
going to expose my client in any way but
so I'm not giving you this much but I
can give you this much with regard to
personality with regard to thoughts with
regard to you know many many things and
so that those people were very helpful
but Joel Harlow really was the key to
finding whitey for me I just want to add
because Johnny is far too humble to ever
say this but and I had said this whether
Johnny is on the stage or not I know
Johnny really really well and he is one
of the most generous and soft-spoken and
soulful men that I've ever met so then
Johnny always physically transforms for
his parts whether exactly whether it's
Sweeney Todd or it's Deadwood it sets
yes please
and the truth is I knew we would get
that right test after test after test
that wasn't an issue but seeing Johnny
go from very soulful and quiet and
gentle man to the man that you have just
seen is mesmerizing not only is the
film's director but that's just a fan
because when he came to set I didn't see
Johnny Depp only very frequently or
infrequently what I actually maybe go by
his trailer after a long day and then
all of that would be gone and I would
say to myself oh my god I'm actually
directing Johnny Depp I've heard Scott
say and John it couldn't have been
filmed anywhere else to walk those
streets to be surrounded by those people
to tell that story you can't do it
anywhere else I saw crazy hard and I saw
Jeff Bridges who is obviously a
brilliant brilliant actor
and is capable of so much but what I saw
in Jeff Bridges was so brave and so and
and the only way that one can arrive at
that arena
is because you have a director who's
brave and is open to like I said the
idea of chance and Scott and I I mean
talked about working together I was
desperate to work with the guy and man
beyond anything I've ever experienced
I've never I've never experienced a
director like this he doesn't allow the
audience to to feel the camera to notice
the camera he makes the camera breathe
as if it's another person you never
really notice it's not like these fancy
kind of shots I mean he he would do huge
huge scenes with a lot of people in a
water and it was so freeing and so
magnificent to play that because you
have this extended period of time where
it's almost like you know you've got
seven minutes of a play almost it blew
me away I'm thinking this is this guy's
third film it's his third film and he's
a master like he's a master it really is
me
boolie and if if phonebooks still
existed I would shoot I would film the
phone book with the mouth